mes chers compatriotes je veux rendre
hommage aux français qui se sont
déplacés bien plus nombreux pour voter
chaque français doit se réjouir car il
n'y a pas de démocratie vivante ni de
débat utile lorsque l'abstention est
trop forte
je veux également remercier les millions
d'électeurs quelle que soit leur
appartenance politique qui se sont
portés au premier tour et bien plus
encore au second sur les listes des
républicains et du centre cette
mobilisation en faveur de nos candidats
du second tour ne doit cependant sous
aucun prétexte
faire oublier les avertissements qui ont
été adressées à tous les responsables
politiques nous compris lors du premier
tour de ces élections régionales
l'unité dans la famille des républicains
l'union avec le centre le refus de toute
compromission avec les extrêmes ont
permis ces résultats ces principes
doivent rester les nôtres dans l'avenir
je veux souligner
s'agissant de l'unité et de l'union
qu'elles ne peuvent pas être de
circonstance mais traduire la volonté
déterminée de tous les responsables de
l'opposition d'avancer ensemble vers les
prochaines échéances
il nous faut maintenant prendre le temps
de débattre au fond des choses
des grandes questions qui angoisse les
français qui attendent de nous des
réponses fortes précise et qui nous
engage je pense à l'europe à la
politique économique au chômage de masse
à notre sécurité à la façon dont est
organisée l'éducation de nos enfants à
l'affirmation de notre identité
ce serait une grave erreur
passé comme trop souvent d'une élection
à une autre comme si les français ne
nous avait rien dit ces débats
approfondis seront notre priorité pour
les mois qui viennent les français
doivent être convaincus que nous aurons
les réponses à la hauteur des enjeux
c'est une exigence de responsabilité qui
nous engage tous
l'heure est plus que jamais au travail
collectif au service de la france
notre devoir et notre responsabilité
c'est de lui donner le meilleur de nous
mêmes je consacrerai à cette tâche
indispensable
toute mon énergie bien sûr mes
félicitations iront à tous ceux des
nôtres qui auront désormais la
responsabilité de diriger une région
à l'heure où je vous parle nous ne
savons pas exactement leur nombre mais
qu'ils sachent que nous sommes fiers de
la campagne qu'ils ont engagées et du et
des résultats qu'ils ont su rassembler
sur leur nos chers compatriotes
vive la république et vive la france